hello welcome to our webinar today we're
going to learn how you can become a
creator from being a player of video
games by using
tile code a platform that was developed
at microsoft research by thomas ball
and i had the pleasure to do a user
study over the summer using this
platform
which we will talk a little bit more
about in this webinar
why does it matter for people to become
not only players of video games but also
creators
today we know that the number of gamers
has increased worldwide and we have
almost around 2.6 billion people who are
active players of video games we also
know that
games and video games can be used as a
source of
enriching creativity and storytelling
and also as a source of critical
critical inquiry
these are a couple of books that we came
across in our research that we think
are underlying these ideas when we talk
about video games and children we know
that children have
a wide experience with games and a rich
intuition about how video games work
we also have seen that games can be a
powerful tool for introducing a
computational vocabulary
today we actually have the widest online
platforms for coding for children
be designed around video games with
examples
as minecraft and make code scratch
which are platforms with millions of
users
and projects that are being shared
however
none of these platforms work on handheld
devices
and this is where tilecode comes into
play
tilecode the best part about it is that
it works on handheld devices
and handheld arcades such as the meow
bit
this handheld arcades are not new
they've been around for a while
and there's a wide community of users
that
exist around these devices however most
of the games currently accessible on
handheld arcades
cannot be programmed on the same devices
which is something that tilecode is
trying to address
all right thank you steph so the tile
code challenge is how to program games
on these small devices
our solution is to constrain the
programming paradigm
so that you can program using the a and
b buttons in the d-pad
yet enable the creation of a variety of
games
and in order to do that we take our lead
from board games
where we have pieces that move on a
chest or checkerboard
so what's critical to those games is
that you have a two-dimensional grid
the grid has squares and you have pieces
and you go from a current state to the
next state
by moving a piece like here in checkers
in tile code what we're going to do is
we're going to have a grid as well it's
called the tile map
it's the foundation of retro video games
and we're going to have backgrounds of
the tiles
as well as sprites that occupy tiles
and then we're going to be able to
program with tile codes so that the
sprites move
in a particular way and so just like
with board games
we have uh pieces which we call sprites
and they move uh two adjacent uh tiles
so in the case of tile code spikes can
move
up down left or right
now we want to make video games not
board games so we have other things we
want
to keep in mind when we're developing
this programming model we want to be
able to respond in real time to user
events like button presses
we have non-player characters that move
on of their own accord
and we want to be able to program those
and furthermore all these activities are
happening
concurrently in parallel so we need a
way to express
uh these concurrent or parallel
activities
we use 2d cellular automata as the
foundation of towel code
in 2d cellular automata you have a grid
or a matrix of cells and each cell has a
value
from a finite set here we have three
possible values blue orange or white
then we give local update rules to take
us from the current state of the
automata to the next state
in this case we're saying that the
middle square here
which is outlined in red becomes orange
in the next state
if the cell above it is dark blue and
the stars mean we don't
care what the values of the other
squares are so this is a local update
rule and these rules are applied in
parallel
so this gives us a lot of power here's a
current state in the cellular automata
where we have six dark blue squares and
the next state given by the local update
rule
would change every cell that's under a
dark blue
cell to orange
so a cellular automata are great but
they're not the best for programming
games
so in tile code we separate backgrounds
and sprites
the backgrounds are like the values we
would put in the cell of an automata
we have four possible backgrounds for
every tile but then we have movable
objects these movable objects are called
sprites
uh and here we have four different
sprites so every tile has a background
but a tile can also contain one or more
sprites
rights furthermore as you recall can
move in one of four directions or they
can
remain at rest and so we also have the
a way to refer to the state that the
sprite just moved in
either left up right down
or the circle means it's at rest so
here's an example
of a sprite controlled by the player
that's moving around
uh the tile map and you can see the
direction that it's moving
uh by the by the arrow
okay so now to tile code the user
interface
uh is created to be able to run on a
gaming handheld
uh you see the d-pad on the left and the
amb buttons on the right
and tile code uses the tile-based
interface
uh as as the way to create games as the
way to design and create games
uh tiles code starts with the load
screen in which you have
eight different slots for the uh
eight different games that you can
create from there
you can select a particular game and go
to the game home screen
where you have access to the four
sprites and four backgrounds you can
choose among different sprites
you can also place the sprites on the
tile map
so to create the initial level of the
game uh you
go to the map editor and uh place the
sprites and change the backgrounds of
the tiles
and finally you can also go to any
sprite or background
and you can use the paint editor to
change
the artwork for that background or
sprite
the the foundation of programming in
tile code is the when do rule
this is a form of guarded command uh on
the left hand side
we have a pattern here we have a pattern
that says there should be a elf at the
center
uh and some green grass or blue grass to
the right so this is like what you saw
in the cellular automata we also have an
event
which is uh the right button press so
the way to read off the what
the when side of this rule is that when
the right button is pressed
and there is this blue grass to the
right of the elf
then we're going to fire the rule and
execute the commands
on the right hand side of the rule which
is the do section
and in the do section we see we're
sending a move right command
to to the elf sprite so we have a very
simple
visual programming paradigm that allows
us to pattern match on the tile map
as well as refer to events and then send
commands
to the sprites that's the essentials of
tile code
so a tile code program then is simply a
set of when do rules
here we see three rules the rule i
described already for moving the sprite
around
the elf sprite if it collides with an
apple then
the apple is destroyed and 10 points are
added to the score this is a second
rule for eating apples and the third
rule says that if the
elf sprite collides into a snake then
it's
a game over so tile code program is a
set of these rules that are essentially
run in parallel
as in the cellular automata uh the one
side of the rule you have different
events we'll see those
there's pattern matching against the
three by three
grid around the sprite and there's a way
to bind a sprite so that you can send
commands to it
so there's a number of very basic
programming language concepts
that are that are embedded in the in the
language
the do commands are quite simple there's
a set of move commands to send to the
sprite
you can destroy a sprite you can paint
the background of a tile so you can
change the background
you can create a new sprite there's a
set of game level commands for game over
and adding score
and there's a special command called
portal which we'll uh describe later
we've created a number of games with
tile code and here we
we show uh the dynamics of six games
uh and under each game is the number of
wendy rules that were
required to create that game so in the
upper left we have the snake game
we have a a a a game
for pushing boxes around turning them
into diamonds we have a game
on the upper right of for eliminating
three in a row or a column we have a
mining game in the lower left
we have a jumping game avoid the snakes
and then we have a sort of dungeon game
and so you can see here uh two to three
handfuls of rules nine to 14 rules
were all that was needed to create these
particular games
and they're quite playable now we're
going to transition to a demo
and we're going to show you how to
create the snake game completely
in tile code using just nine rules to
just give you an idea of the game
informally
uh the snake the user has control of a
snake that's moving continuously
through the tile map uh here the game
ends
if the snake head collides with a
barrier or the snake body as shown by my
very fine
art so here's the snake colliding into a
wall that's going to be game over
the snake should act like a snake well
what does that mean it means every
segment of the snake follows the segment
in front of it
so somehow we need to code the snake to
move like a snake
and finally when the snake eats an apple
it's a funny sort of snake
it grows by one segment every time it
eats an apple
okay so now uh given all that setup the
informal description of the game let's
transition
into tile code to see how it actually
works in practice
okay here we are in the uh tile code uh
application in the in the web browser
and we have a four sprite says at our
disposal we have what i call the snake
parent the snake child the apple and the
apple core
and we have some backgrounds so these
have been already set up
we have a tile map which we've already
created where we've placed the snake
and some apples it's a rather large
level there's some apples inside ponds
and so this is a static image and it
represents the initial state
of our game so what we'd like to do now
is step by step
add behavior to the game this is uh the
programming aspect
uh the first thing we like to do is give
the user control of the snake parent
so in this page we have a we have a set
of different types
of rules we can choose from we want to
choose the press event because we want
to
have the snake parent uh move based on
what the user does
so we select the right arrow of the
d-pad and we get a rule
uh and what we want to do simply here is
have the snake move right
whenever whenever the right button is
pressed
now tile code does something for the
first sprite which is usually the player
sprite
and it generalizes the rule for us to
the other three directions
so here's the rule for the button up the
button up press event
where we move up we move left
for our left button press and down for a
down button press
with a single rule that we've given by
example we now can make the snake move
one step at a time so notice every time
i click on the d-pad the snake moves
okay and if i hold the button down it
keeps moving
but recall we want the snake to move
continuously so once
i press the button it should keep moving
in that direction
so for that we have to go back to the
rule selector menu
and we have to think about uh what
happens when the snake has
changed state and in particular uh we
have
uh this this rule that says the snake
has just moved
right one square so this is the state of
the snake
it has just moved into the middle square
and it has just moved right
so in this case in the absence of user
events
uh and uh there are none in this case we
are going to keep the snake moving right
so with that simple rule a snake that
is that has started in motion continues
in motion
so now you can see we take one button
press in any direction
we change the direction of the snake and
it keeps moving
in that direction we want the snake also
to start moving from the resting state
and so here i'll show off the feature
where we can change
in a new rule uh the direction or the
predicate
uh over the direction to the circle so
circle denotes the snake at rest
and at in the initial state state in the
initial state uh
all sprites are at rest so in this case
we want to start the snake moving right
and we actually want to stop
generalizing if we were to
keep generalization in this case the
snake would randomly choose one of the
four directions to move but we really
want it to start moving right
so now with with no user event the stake
snake
the snake starts moving to the right
okay but as you notice it can move
anywhere and there's
um there's no particular actions that
take place
so let's return to the rule selector
screen and
add a collision event so we call this
smash events
we're going to code a rule for when the
snake parent
crashes into various items so we want
the game to be over when the snake
crashes into the wall so we select that
notice we can
we can add the wall to the set by
clicking there we
also uh we don't this snake doesn't like
to swim
or going through the grass a strange
snake so we
checked that and also if the snake wraps
back around on itself
and smashes into one of its children
that's following it
then it's going to be game over so we've
we've chosen three things
to detect collisions on and we're going
to just use the upside down trophy
so now we can see when we go into the
wall it's game over
when we go into the water it's game over
and if we
loop back around it's came over okay so
let's uh let's actually
not uh well the snakes like the grass so
they like to hide in the grass so let's
let the snake
go into the grass and we can see now
that it does that okay so now we've got
a collision rules
now we what we haven't done uh we
haven't done anything with the snake
children
so the snake child we can go and select
it and we see there are no rules present
for the snake child so the first thing
we like to do is make sure
that the children start moving uh in the
same direction as the parent
and if you'll recall with that's the to
move right so let's
do that simple rule the snake child at
rest
moves uh to the right okay and what you
see is that they're inching along
so why aren't they moving smoothly the
reason is
when the snake moves uh to the right it
enters the moving state
and it remembers that for one round but
we don't have any rule for
the snake child moving we just have it
at rest so it takes one round for it to
move
another round for it to transition back
to the resting state and then
this rule fires again so that's why uh
the snake children inch along
okay as we saw in the powerpoint we want
the snake
children to follow uh those in front of
them
so the way we're going to do that is
with some new rules and here's where we
show off the power of
pattern matching as well as parallelism
so when would we like to keep the snake
child moving
uh to the right well if it
if it should keep moving to the right
then there should be
it should be following uh the element uh
ahead of it and where would that element
be
well it would be to the tile to the
right and it would either be
the parent or another child so
um so so we want the snake we certainly
want it to keep moving to the right
at least in this case but furthermore we
want to know that that segment itself
just moved to the right so this is a
snake that's just moving along happily
in one direction okay so we're going to
have the snake child keep moving to the
right if to the right
there's another snake element that just
moved to the right as well
and we want to actually generalize this
to four directions
so that holds for going up or any
direction so this is the snake moving in
a straight line
and as we see if we let it go now then
the children are just moving along
but notice as soon as the snake parent
veers off
then the snake children return to
inching along
so we definitely need some more cases
so another case is going to be that the
snake child should move
up next so let's think about when it
should move up
well if it needs to be following uh the
segment ahead of it then there should be
a segment above it
and furthermore that segment should just
have
moved up so here we're turning a corner
so the segment ahead of us took a
counter-clockwise move
we moved this segment moved to the right
so now it should follow its leader by
moving up
and we should generalize that as well
two three more directions
okay so now we can see that as long as
we're moving counterclockwise
everybody's following along
but as soon as we move clockwise uh
we're back in the same old
state with inching along so we have one
more case and that's for
a snake a child to move down and i think
you can probably guess
at this point where the leader should be
and what direction that the leader
should have been moving
and again we're going to generalize that
rule to four directions
so now we have a complete snake
that moves wherever the parent go
wherever the parent goes the children
should follow and you notice that this
works for no matter how many children
there are so if we go
to the tile map and we increase the
length of the snake
by i don't know three more children
following along
then the pattern matching will just
apply to all of those
so this is the power of the cellular
automata approach
and the power we have in tile code is
that the rules apply
over the entire tile map and as a result
you can
achieve some really nice uh parallel
effects
uh and behavior um with very little code
so i'm gonna
change the snake back actually let's
make it a snake of size
three altogether okay so what you've
seen
so far is we've we've seen the complete
dynamic of
essentially moving having the user move
the snake and having the snake act like
a snake as well as collide
so that's been a number of rules now we
need to
actually consider how to make the snake
grow this is going to be another smash
rule
in this case the snake parent is
smashing or colliding with the apple
and in this case what we want to do is
get rid of the apple so this is the
destroy
command and this destroy command applies
to the sprite to its left that's the
apple
um but we want to leave a leftover
it in its place and you'll see the
reason for doing that we're going to
leave an apple core
so in place of the apple which was just
destroyed
we're going to create a new sprite which
is this apple core
uh it'll be left at the same the same
position
and it'll be created at the position and
we're going to increase the uh
score by 10. so let's see what this
simple rule does
this simple rule means that whenever we
go over
the apple it immediately gets changed
into
the apple core whoops i missed it and we
see that this
that the uh that the score increases
so now how are we going to accomplish
the final
uh step which is to grow the snake um so
this is an interesting part
you notice that the apple because of the
movement of the snake when it eats the
apple
it will continue to move over the apple
core
until at some point the
the last child in the snake
moves past it so here's uh
here's a uh a snake child that's just
moved to the right
and we want to consider the case when
that
it is just past the apple core okay
that looks great and it's the last one
and what that means
is that in the tile that contains the
apple core there should be no
snake child and we do that with the red
do not go here son so that means we
don't want to see
uh this sprite in the tile okay so this
picture
is a little misleading if we hover over
you can see it so
uh there should be a tile uh the tile to
the left
of the snake child that just moved right
should have an apple core in it but
should not have a snake child so that's
the pattern we're matching
okay what are we going to do in this
case in this case it's time to get rid
of the apple
core completely and in order to grow the
snake we're going to
add a new snake child at the same
location
and we're going to tell it to follow its
leader which means to move in the
direction
of uh of the child that used to be the
last child
so now we've grown the snake by one uh
and we also want this rule to apply
in all four directions so now
as you see if we go over the snake as
soon as the last
as soon as the last child goes over the
apple core
or passes it then the snake grows
and so at some point we can run into
ourselves oops
all right so that is uh the demo
complete demo of the snake game
which took us uh nine rules
uh in all so i hope you've appreciated
uh the tile code program you've seen uh
tile code was designed to be a visual
language
to have a sort of close mapping between
english
and rules so we have a way to read out
in english
you know the meaning of a when do clause
we don't have to think about the entire
program at once
you see that parallelism and pattern
matching are the primary structuring
mechanisms pattern matching takes place
in the three by three grid
around a central sprite and the patterns
apply wherever they match
on the tile code on the tile code tile
map
this is quite different than what you
have probably experienced
or might have seen in uh game
programming environments
that use blocks such as scratch or make
code the emphasis
there is on composable coding blocks uh
using the blockley framework
where you can drag and drop blocks
together to create
essentially a structured program uh
structured control flow is really the
primary
structuring mechanism of these
environments and
although they have the ability for
concurrency uh the emphasis is really on
sequential
programming as opposed to data parallel
pattern matching which you've
seen in intel code um tile code was
created really to
be able to run on these very small
devices and to have an editing paradigm
that would fit
with the tile the tile map
games where a scratch and make code have
the ability to express a wide variety of
games not just style
tile based games most importantly tile
code works on small devices like this
miyabit
so here you can see the home screen of
tile code
and if i press the default button you
can see the cursor moving around
now i'm going to tell you a little bit
more about our user study and the
workshops we've done together with
families over the summer
in our study we had 16 families from all
over
north america that participated in four
to five weekly sessions
of 45 minutes each family was given the
opportunity to
engage with coding activities at home
and also participated in these sessions
with
with the researchers with us we took
field notes from each of the sessions
and also recorded the sessions
i'm going to show you a video where you
can get an overview of
how the children and the parents engage
with tile code over
this study
[Music]
now in our study we had a this
four sessions so i will present what
happened in each session of the study
in the first session the family watched
described and modified three games we
presented them with the game of snake
which tom presented earlier
boulder dash and bejeweled in a second
session
we asked the families to complete a form
for designing their own game using tile
code
and then start to build it in the third
session
we presented the families with a rich
vocabulary of game patterns
and coding patterns and encourage them
to pick only three of these patterns and
combine them
in a game that they would like to build
lastly
in our final session we allow the
families to
again watch three videos of uh
three video games built with tile code
and describe how these games work
the final video games were pac-man
space invaders and a conveyor belt game
what we found in our study was that
overall the children and the parents
were curious about how the video games
work
and initially they engage in various
levels of richness in the way they were
describing these games
all the families had ideas about how to
make the video games more fun
but initially they had a limited ability
in scoping how
they would like to make these game
changes
in the second and third session what we
saw is that children started with
complex games idea
game ideas many of our participants
actually wanted to build minecraft intel
code
we saw that older children inquired
about the platform abilities
and tried to scope their designs
according to what the platform can do
most of the time children will spend a
long time
in designing the characters of the game
and the backgrounds of the game in
creating the assets of the game
and as they were going along and
learning how to build the different
rules and code their games
sometimes they would update their game
narrative just so it would be able to
fit the roles they knew how to
how to program once they had a story in
mind the narrative piece was quite
important
children weren't so intimidated to start
coding
it's almost like they were very
motivated to make their character come
to life to make their game come to life
another thing we found at the very end
was that most of the participants
guessed the correct rules in our final
guest
role game and that the their
descriptions
their final descriptions of games got
much more complex they were able to
create direct parallels between game
events and
the rules that were associated with
creating these events
we had much richer descriptions in
uh describing these games from both from
the kids and parents
and overall we found that children and
parents collaborated
and engaged uh in a balanced way with
the platform and with the game creation
throughout the study
i'm going to show you some examples of
children games that were built in this
study
the first example is a race game so this
was a very simple game that was built by
a
10 year old girl in the very first
session of our study
where she had two animals a dog
and a squirrel as she described it
trying to race towards the
finish line and the game was very simple
because she learned how to make the the
dog
moved by itself and then the goal of the
game was to actually try to move the
squirrel
faster than the the dog in reaching the
finish line
and this was fun because the automated
movement for the dog was quite faster
than the player could move the squirrel
so by default the player would lose the
game all the time so then
programmatically
our young participant had to figure out
how can she slow down the automatic
motion for the dog in order for the
player to have a chance to win
um so this was an example of a very
simple game built only with
three rules but which was very engaging
both for for the family and for other
players another example was this double
snake
game just like in the demo that tom
showed earlier
of the snake game we had this demo for
kids
however we had a family where the first
thing the first modification that our
our
siblings in this case tried to make was
to create a double
snake so besides the original green
snake they made a yellow snake
which was trying to compete with the
snake controlled by the user and eat the
apples first so it was like an automated
snake moving around across the screen
which was not controlled by the player
the third game was the
underwater game so in this game we had
two siblings that
created a game or about an explorer
that would go underwater and try to move
across different type of coral
while collecting the diamonds and trying
to stay away from the shark
the way the explorer would win this game
is by reaching
the end of a maze made of quarrel so
this was
quite a more complicated game with a
very intricate map and the
siblings in this case created all the
backgrounds and the game levels
so this was a type of game that they
made at the end of the study
so we what we can see in these three
examples is
different levels of complexity of game
mechanics and of
programming rules however we see that
children were able to
identify at different stages of the
study how to use the platform
and were able to create their own games
and their own rules
with the platform disregarding of how
much experience
experience they had with tile code
another thing we found in the study was
that
the parents played a crucial role many
times when the children would not
understand
one of the concepts or the terms used in
our platform
the parents would step in and were able
to explain
in a language that their children
understood what the
platform does or what's expected from
them in a specific
instruction of the game and moreover the
parents knew what their kids are into
so they would always prompt them like
you like going and playing with this
type of game why don't you try to do
something similar to that
um we also saw that the children would
spend more time and would be more
engaged with the platform if their
parents were around and they were
involved so in general one of the
important lessons especially right now
when children are mostly learning from
home
together with their families for us was
to think of
how we design not only for children but
also for parents and for family learning
we see we've seen a lot of opportunities
for creative personal expression
in our study especially when
watching how much time children would
spend in
creating their own characters their own
backgrounds and we see a lot of
opportunities for
sharing these assets in future versions
of tile code
believing that it's quite important like
one simple
element in the background or one change
like in the character
will lead to a completely new story a
completely new opportunity for creating
a new game
so allowing users to be able to share
these assets and these ideas
uh would lead to much richer engagement
with the platform
in in the study we also seen a lot of
parallels between
uh gameplay design and game programming
just like in a game play design
user has to create a game plan and it
has to be aware of the game state
we have the game goals and the game rule
mechanics in the case of tile code
and in the case of game programming we
need to make a game program
uh design where we also keep track of
the machine state in our case the map
and where the objects are on the map
there there are goals for the game
and their rules and mechanics for for
our
system for our machine and for our
program
so we see talcott as a unique
opportunity for teaching children about
powerful computational ideas because
it builds on this low entry point of
video games that are very appealing for
kids
but it has a direct analogy and a direct
parallel with
concepts from computer science
that are easily more more easily
presented to children
in this scenario of a game planning
rather than a program planning to
conclude we
saw in this user study that tile code
can be applied
playground for powerful ideas and it
became this playground for powerful
ideas because it allowed both children
and parents to code
play and update their game data as they
went along
so allowing them to engage with
video games from these three different
perspectives at all times
was extremely um useful and it lowered
the barrier of entry
for people that didn't have a lot of
experience with video games and with
programming before
i hope you can appreciate that through
the programming demos as well as
steph's user studies that there are some
really powerful computational ideas in
tile code
we've seen notions of data and state
local knowledge
pattern matching parallelism uh
conflicts what i didn't show you was
randomization
um there's a there's underlying logic so
there's a lot of really
uh great ideas to discover there in a
very very small language
the next steps for tile code we have
thoughts based on the user studies we
did
on improving the language and the user
interface
based on our learnings we're also
thinking of a web app
that takes us into the realm of
touch and gives us more possibilities
for
interaction as well as potentially the
incorporation of natural language as
informal specification finally we think
that
uh it would be interesting to uh
look at how to make uh something like
tile code more accessible especially
with
incorporation of natural language
uh if you want to learn more about tile
code
and experience the web app yourself then
uh please visit
aka dot ms slash tile code
you can get access to the web
application there uh
tile code is open source on github at
this url
and tilecode is uh built with makecode
arcade
um and so i also encourage people
to check that out as well steph and i
wrote
introductory blog which you can find
here and with that
we would love to have your questions in
the question and answer
period to follow thank you very much
hello everybody this is tom ball uh with
stefania druga
hello hi steph uh thanks for attending
this webinar from player to creator
designing video games on gaming
handhelds with microsoft tile code
this is a live q and a and over the next
15 minutes we're going to be answering
top questions submitted uh by you the
audience
um so uh let's
let's get started are our step do you
want to take first question
okay uh
i we have some pending questions from
the chat as well
if uh that we can go to
before uh we get new questions
so i know there were a couple of
questions
around from vidima vidimnas
around learning outcomes and how
tal code compares with other existing
programming languages for
kids and then you know like how does
will it support if it doesn't support
yet the
online learning and remixing or
collaboration
[Music]
in terms of learning outcomes and how do
we measure
what children learn in our user initial
user study and this is the first
user study that was done with tile code
we took an approach of not focused on
instructionism but more focused on
constructionism
so we actually wanted to see if children
that never programmed with tile code
before
or that had limited prior coding
experience
were actually able to create their own
games and we wanted to look at how
different these games would be
if how well were they able to translate
their ideas their initial concept for a
game
into a game they were able to program
and play with their parents or their
friends
so that was something we uh uh
that was our approach for measuring the
learning
in our user studies but we also looked
at language so we actually
wanted to see how children and parents
develop a personal ontology
around the way they describe video games
and the way they describe programming
concepts
used in these video games so it turns
out that
in the very beginning many of the
families when they were asked to
describe video games like
that they would see in videos would have
more simple descriptions or
would not be able to uh identify as
many elements of the game or events
or elements in the background that
matter but when they got the chance to
get their own experience with
programming these games
not only did they develop the more rich
vocabulary but they were also able to
just perceive and observe many more
elements in the game that
matter so i think that was
uh this was our approach to observing
analyzing and designing for supporting
learning during
these workshops and activities with
families but it's only the beginning so
there's much more to
be done there
great thank you steph um we have a
another question
um about the limitations of tile code um
you only allow four sprites and and and
and and four backgrounds it's
restrictive and yes by design healthcare
is meant to be uh quite a restrictive
little sandbox
um but um but i think what we've seen is
that
uh you can actually do quite a bit of
expression within that
uh certainly the design of file code was
made so that it can really run
on low-cost handhelds in fact um the
meow that that i showed
in the video only has 96 kilobytes of
memory
yet you know you can put eight different
games in it and um
and so that's so it's restricted by
design but in the future
we definitely imagine having more
powerful handhelds
um that could have uh more sprites
as well as maybe you know um a richer
richer sort of programming
uh interface um so thanks to pedro for
that uh for that question
jeff would you like to take one yes so
i see sydney asked us um i'm guessing
sydney is a parent and she asked us
a lot of games now especially mobile
games
that many children have exposure to are
more immediately rewarding did the
children show a preference for more
complex
games that they didn't have to make
themselves
this is a really good question i think
definitely
you know the emergence of tools like
tile code and
any other new programming platform for
kids
tackling video games doesn't happen in a
void we need to
be aware and take into account the media
ecosystem in which
children and families are finding
themselves these days especially with
the learning from home especially with
the increased time
on online so
one thing i can tell you is that i was
actually surprised to see how many of
the children actually wanted to start
with a very complex game so we had uh
three cases three families where the
first game children wanted to build on
tile code was minecraft
and as you can imagine that is quite
challenging
uh we definitely came up with creative
ways of representing a 3d world into a
2d world um like how could we
make the sprite move slower to simulate
this climbing
um you know a hill for example or things
like that that these were some of the
ideas we had
but in general i think once children
got understood how the platform works
they didn't shy away from complexity on
the contrary and i think like
one of the things that is quite powerful
about tile code is that it provides
these different perspectives like
if the children get stuck with the rules
they get stuck in the code they can go
to the map and change the map they can
go to the sprites and add a new sprite
or like maybe transform even these
limitations that tom just talked about
like
we only have four sprites but we have
four backgrounds maybe we need an extra
sprite we will use one of the
backgrounds be a sprite on so like a lot
of the constraints
actually fueled their creativity
and they had to work around these
constraints and i almost
think that was helpful um and
i i didn't see them shy away from
complexity
i think the main difference between the
immediately more like candy crush or
like the immediately rewarding
games that children have access to and
the games they built themselves
is this notion of agency that they
are in control of what happens in the
game they can create their own character
they can create their own uh game art
they can make their own rules they can
make a game that is so impossible to
play that they are the only ones who
know how to win and they like that
um and actually that's that's what we
were trying to
to do is to allow children not to be
only consumers of commercial games but
uh maybe start on some of these uh
elements of video games that they like
but allow them to be creators as well
great thanks steph there are two
questions one from
ross and one from the minutes
uh about sharing and remixing and that
that's definitely something that
uh that is for future work in tile code
um right now when you put uh
when you're in the web browser the game
state is
is saved locally in browser local
storage and when you're on a tile code
device such as the meow bit
the program that the the game assets
rather the programs the sprites
are stored in flash storage uh and we
don't have a good
uh sharing solution implemented what
what is possible though
is that um when you've created a game on
a handheld device and you plug it into a
laptop or a desktop
it appears as a mass storage device over
usb
and you can drag essentially the tile
code program
out of you can copy it off the device
onto your desktop or laptop and when you
do that
all the settings that contain your game
assets
are are stored in that file so then if
you take that file
you have the game assets and if you were
to give it or email it to a friend
who had a meow bit they could install
that same file and then they would see
your games so it's very low level type
of sharing
we really want to have a much free form
solution where regardless of where you
create the games and the game assets you
can share them
so clearly the web app uh needs to be
able to export
game assets to the gaming handheld and
vice versa and we would obviously
also like to encourage sharing you know
when you have an internet connection
over the web another another idea that
we have is we do have the ability
to network uh the gaming devices so for
example if you had a game
on your arcade handheld and a friend had
one
uh another handheld um you could connect
them
via a a cable and just battery powered
and potentially have a user interface
to um to share the game to copy it over
or do multiplayer
so there's there's lots of interesting
aspects to sharing
as well as remixing um and we intend to
explore that in the future but we're
going to need to
create some more infrastructure for that
great question thank you thank you very
much
um steph i'll hand it back to you
yeah we have a question from guy tri she
asked many great questions
and this question is asking about the
role of parents
she's asking if we see any interesting
ways in which parents describe
computational ideas
while teaching their kids any analogies
metaphors anything else
um and the short answer is yes
many ways they were much better at
describing and translating some of the
computational ideas to their kids than
we were because they know their children
better
um there was a reason why we did this
study with
families and not only children and i
think
in today's world and especially with all
the online
learning parents find themselves much
more involved
in children learning not only of
computational ideas but in general
and in my research i've been working
with
children and families for more than
eight years now
i always found that having parents
involved
plays a huge role especially from a
social emotional perspective children
love to have the validation of their
parents when they build something be
able to share that
be able to have their parents
encouragement
and the type of workshops or the type of
engagement one would do in a classroom
or in an informal learning setting
only matters if it's further encouraged
and supported at
home so in my work and in my research
it's very important to
work with parents as well and not only
children work with families
specifically in our study it was
interesting because
the tile code interface
and programming paradigm is new for kids
so having parents be there and
help us build some conceptual bridges
was essential
and very often they would know how to
reference this to an experience or
another game that the child play or
something the child liked
um that we didn't know i had the case of
a mom
who where her her daughters were asking
why the princess looks very different
on the map versus how it looks like when
we're building the rules
and she had to explain you know down
scaling resolution to her daughters
in a language that i would have never
know
how to use how to use or how to
formulate
um and it was just incredible to see
that actually even
very young children as young as seven
could understand this kind of concepts
if explained right and with lots of
examples
so i think this was my favorite part
from
our user study the fact that we could
work with families that
when the parents had the time to get
involved it re
it showed it really helped with children
getting to do
more complicated projects faster
so i actually think it's important
for many other tool designers and
technology designers
to design for families and not only for
children
great thank you thank you steph steph
you have a you have another question
maybe you can hop to right now
from the diminish uh who's um
who has a question number 30
yes uh viet minas is asking if
um the user after the user study with 7
to 12 years old
we think the platform works well with
this age group
and if we would test the age range when
testing again
we we think that the platform worked
well for this age group
obviously the older children were able
to
build more complex projects faster but
the seven-year-olds eight-year-olds were
able to engage with the platform and
they enjoyed playing with the platform
they enjoyed building their own games as
well
so it wasn't um they the younger
children and the older child
children both enjoyed and
were able to engage with the platform it
was more of a difference in level of
complexity of the games they would make
and one thing that tom and i talked
about
and there are many like future steps
above for tile code which i'll let
tom talk about more in a second but one
one uh potential way to mitigate the age
difference
is to provide um more beginner
version like with some of the features
be
enabled or automated or hidden
and then have like this kind of
progressive disclosure as
the users become more familiar with the
platform i know someone else was asking
about this like if some of the
features are by default enabled to a
specific mode
that's something we played with during
the study as well for example
do we make certain rules generalized
like when we have the main character of
the game that the camera follows
and we made a role to teach the
character to move
to the right do we want that rule to
apply to left
to up and down or do we need to make
four rules which can be very tedious
right
so we actually made the decision to
generalize certain rules
but sometimes you know children had
different intuition about
how the rules should generalize so this
is you know there are a lot of research
questions here
which are um still like
worth exploring and testing and maybe
have
more user studies definitely have more
user studies
larger group of participants but in
terms of age i think this worked well
even if the age range in our study was
quite broad
and i think for for future studies being
able to have
some sort of progressive disclosure
feature would be very helpful
great yeah thanks steph yeah there's
definitely a lot of complexity you can
get
into with tile code and thinking about
scaffolding or
or starting with very simple rules and
then increasing
complexity uh and doing that with some
support in the uis
is definitely something we want to look
at um daniel also
asked and maybe this is the question
both of us have to try to answer he said
in the example of the game with the
shark how do you link the shark with the
main character
how does the shark know the current
position um
so by default in tile code the first
sprite the sprite on the left
is the sprite that generally the camera
follows
we haven't um we haven't done uh
a good job yet on on sort of separating
the sprites
any sprite can be user controlled but
the the camera follows the first one
um and um again the sprites can only
respond to one another
essentially by this pattern matching in
the three by three neighborhood um
so so there's if sprites are separated
by a long distance
in the uh in the in the matrix or the
grid
there's no way for them to know the
coordinates or the existence of the
other
uh sprites that's by design with the
sort
sort of cellular automata approach
everything is done locally
so i hope that answers the question
daniel um
and i can i can give an example as well
how do you play it out thank you stuff
uh yeah so um sometimes you know like
because in other platforms like scratch
or
uh alice or like the coordinates of the
characters matter and like
we build programming logic based on the
xy
position here it was different like
because the camera was just following
the explorer
the sharks were in the maze and the
sharks like the children learn for
example how to animate the sharks like
just like in the game with snake
in the tutorial like um
some children wanted to build a second
snake that would just like go around the
screen by itself
so other characters can be animated and
they will appear in the camera even if
um the camera is not following them and
then build a collision rule
so what happens if the explorer
runs into the shark then you know the
explorer dies
so there's a collision rule for what
happens when these two characters meet
and then of course like for animating
the shark like for deciding
when and where um does the shark move
um there were lots of ways to do that so
either by deciding uh the shark should
always move when it's in a certain type
of background
or it should move um if it hits
something
or so so children got to play it was
more
this kind of designing for emergent
behavior
uh and creating rules for what happens
if certain characters meet or certain
characters meet
with a specific background and things
like that
but it was a different logic than trying
to
account and keep track of specific
positions for each character yeah
thank you yeah there are no arrays
there's no iteration over arrays it's
all
sort of implicit by the pattern matching
uh and that
that's something that that i think is
quite powerful um
but but it also it also can yield some
surprising results because you're
you're doing all this pattern matching
in parallel
um i had a question i wanted to go
back to from charlotte uh about
uh sure lot is asking us if there's any
plan to offer
ai control non-player sprites
in the future and i love this question
because actually kids asked us this too
and
i remember at some point like when their
games were getting more complex
and we had an eight-year-old boy who was
like why can't i just
make talco generate the levels i'll tell
it like i need
seven snakes and so so they were like
looking for automation of certain parts
of the platform
kids also asked us for um
voice support for debugging they they
were like basically
asking us to replace ourselves as
facilitators like when the study is over
um which was interesting my research
focuses
on ai education for kids
and i'm right now actually looking
specifically at program synthesis
so trying to see if
there are any ways for the platform even
if it's in tile code or cognimates which
is a platform that i
built or other programming languages
where the the platform itself
can support the users either to build
the right rule
or to build rules that would be
complementary to what they're doing
or to generate like random elements in
on the map
so this is this is really i think the
future of coding for
kids and there's so much to explore
there and i
one thing that i would encourage um
the folks who are still with us today to
think about
is to really think about new
opportunities for learning that this
could open up
and not only from the perspective of we
have this programming concept
we have this like computer science
theory and we need to see if kids will
learn it
well more like what are all the ways in
which they could create with these tools
and are there new ways for them to
create and
code with these two tools that were not
available or possible before
how can we create new mediums for them
so
i think there are a lot of exciting
future options and i know
tom also looked into program synthesis
for
for tile code and i'll let him talk more
about that
yeah yeah thanks steph yeah the the sort
of the data pattern
matching of the cellular automata turns
out to be very closely related to
convolutional neural networks and um
you can you can actually take sort of
tile code programs and
and run them and have a neural net sort
of learn rules
uh we haven't done that but but there is
research so i think
i think having this sort of notion that
of
of computation uh as a big part of
computation is this pattern matching as
the patterns
extend from a three by three grid you
know to a chessboard size to larger size
you're going to need to recognize
patterns and you might not be able to
code them all by hand so how are you
going to do better pattern recognition
so there's
there's really a fascinating uh question
there
um as well and um and i think
uh you know i think that's very that's
very interesting
so i think we're we're at a one hour so
i think we have um maybe one more
question
uh uh that is question 31 steph i think
this one
is for you so why don't we make that our
last question
and uh if you have more um you can
please ask them we'll try to
answer them offline uh
yeah uh vivinas is asking about
uh future resources to learn about uh
theories academic background that are
you know relevant
for the user studies we talked about um
and the research project
idea i was going to put my scholar link
and send it um there are
a lot of different theories like we
looked at the theory of
cognitive continuum and basically
how do we build on initial children's
intuitions
around the the concepts that are being
presented in the video games
and on the platform and then over time
either through facilitating not only the
engagement with the platform and the
prompts they get on the platform
but also facilitating the engagement
with their peers or with their parents
they can move from an intuitive way of
thinking
to a more quasi-experimental way of
thinking so
there are a lot of theories around
collaborative sense making for example
that apply here
and the work of andy decessa in changing
minds and building on p
primes for kids is very relevant as well
so
basically what we want is to enable
the children to become tiny scientists
like for them to
build a lot of different hypotheses and
have the tools and platforms that
support them to test this hypothesis
in a more seamless way because in that
way they will be able to
prototype and test many more ideas and
if they have
wrong assumptions correct them on their
own terms
great thank you steph we'd like to thank
everybody for attending today we really
appreciate your participation
and interest uh if you want to learn
more we have a bunch of resources
and the resource list to the right of
your screen that includes the website
which has the microsoft tilecode web app
as well as um documentation
and videos
pointing out how you can create your own
games
we also have uh we also have a project
homepage and a paper if you want to read
more about it
we really look forward to seeing how you
build on on this research
we welcome suggestions too
please email us at tile code
tilecodemicrosoft.com and
that's all thanks have thanks very much
and have a great day everyone
thank you take care thanks for joining
thank you steph
bye-bye everyone
you